told
[Applause]
[Music]
you
perfect
[Music]
perfect perfect what's up everybody I am
Thomas dope as Yola whatever you want to
call me I'm with my co-host Marty O'Neal
what's up guys what up this is the dope
as usual podcast we're talk about life
problems drugs accomplishments and
everything in between today we have a a
very very requested fan favorite this is
the Ralph Barbosa episode thanks for
being here man what's up thank for
having me thank you thank you yeah no
fans no fans were asking for me by the
way those were all Bots I created oh and
then I still was just like I don't know
man I don't know if I should do the Pod
and then I was on the Bots like yeah get
Ral Barbosa out I love creating that
whole supply and demand you know we
actually talked about this before
remember we talked about a certain
rapper like mhm
I think he boted us happened before I
don't even know how I don't how B work
but it's I always know like oh lead it
back zero post zero po it's always the
guy with nothing and like 30 Bots that's
po I don't know computers but so let's
get on to something that's very very
very relevant and huge you have a
Netflix special coming out on Halloween
yes kaanga it's called cabanga are you a
super teenage mut isja Turtle fan uh I'm
a fan but I really named the cab Bunga
because to me the word canga means like
a uh like canga means like when you it's
like it's like one word of of being able
to phrase like that feeling of like hell
yeah or like badass oh you're just
saying it say it yeah and I couldn't say
I couldn't Nam the special badass or
hell yeah so I just named it cow Bunga
cow Bunga so you're just saying it like
cool badass just literally using it like
the
teenage I got to do a special I was like
badass hell yeah cow Bunga that's not
what I I thought you like oh I love
donat so [__] much that I had to name
it this nah all right all right I just I
just wanted to know I love Ninja Turtles
don't get me wrong but it's just so much
more simple than I thought yeah all
right did you see the new one yeah I
liked it I felt like they made Donatello
too much of the funny guy I'm I'm I
don't like change you
know yo and then they they put Mikey and
improv classes which is to I guess imply
that he wants to be funny but he's not
he's working on it yeah oh I didn't
watch it I'm lost right now well the
special's coming out how how do you feel
how you feeling this this your first big
world I would says worldwide thing yeah
um I don't know it's all right I don't
know how to feel until after it's out
there you know I'm excited uh edit
editing it it's like a long process man
like you got to yeah you got to like the
people who edit it the people who
actually do like the [__] work on the
computers they're sending you the
version then you like send them back
notes like can you change this can you
add this what whatever and then they're
like all right and then it's just like
you watch it so many times you're you're
[__] having them edit things that
probably like don't even matter I'm like
yo on this joke can you change the
camera angle from this angle can you
show matter it matters matters I guess I
don't know but then but then it throws
it throws my mind off cuz I'm like what
if it was right the way they had it and
then my my camera angle change now is
the reason I have a shitty podcast I
mean a shitty uh special like so I don't
know but at the end of the day like I
mean I like the jokes I did
and I mean it's out there so what were
your nerves like I I was hella nervous
man like we I wanted to stay warm I
wanted to keep running the
hour and we did it in my hometown
because in my hometown I can I mean I
can [__] go up on any stage for as
long as I want you know
so like for four nights leading up to
the taping night we did two shows a
night at like a couple different ven
and and I just man it was some of the
funnest shows that I had but on tape
night I had like the the worst shows of
the
week someone [__] it up or n it's just
like the crowds were just like I don't
know if maybe the fact that it was a
taping maybe the crowds were nervous
they did these announcements before the
show like yo don't get up like don't be
like yelling and stuff like and maybe
they got too tight or something I don't
know what it was but like I remember
Tuesday night and Thursday night of that
week we taped on a Friday but Tuesday
and Thursday were the greatest shows
some of the greatest shows I've ever had
like I wish we would have just taped
those and then Friday it was just like
it's all right you know but if you watch
the special maybe maybe you'll you won't
see it but I I'm just saying it because
I just had these [__] crazy amazing
crowds and then I'm comparing it to that
week you know so if you watch the
special maybe you're just like [__] you
talking about it's fine or you might be
like yeah [__] that oh [__] I don't know
I don't know that's it that's that's
that's the only I guess hard part is
just the wait like waiting to see how
people are going to react to the special
you know what I mean how long ago did
you did you film it we filmed it in um I
want to say it was July oh so it's oh no
that's a long time to be waiting to see
your special done okay never mind 3
months is a long ass time yeah and then
I can't even remember like which jokes I
cut cuz it it's like an hour but I ended
up doing like an hour 10 hour 15 or
something I know I cut some of the jokes
out you know what I mean and I can't
remember which ones now so even now I'm
just like bro I'm so tired of watching
it though from like editing it it's like
when you say a word too many times and
and it doesn't sound like a word anymore
yeah I just watched it so many times and
I'm just like it just sounds like white
noise at this time like it just sounds
like noise bro I don't I stopped
watching it I've already turned in like
the final version to Netflix like it's
it's in their hands now now it just has
to be released
so we'll see that's like turn to
homework like I know I crushed my essay
but my teacher might be you [__] I
don't know you ever like uh I don't know
what the state tests were out here sat n
sat n sat n test number two pencils I
never brought one bro we had the tax
test in Texas and I think now it's like
the star but anyway you ever like you do
your test you look it over one more time
you turn it in and you're just like
thinking about like a certain question
you're just like did I Circle C on that
one or did I Circle A like now which kid
were you were you the kid that like yo I
didn't study see A B C D D D D D all the
way down I hope I did good I just
remember what I could exactly but I
remember [__] cuz I never do my homewor
were you were you a good kid like good
student though I was pretty good in most
classes you know how to take notes where
it's like that split uh not exactly you
know I'm talking about people did the
line those girls always L I didn't
understand that [__] Bro there was what
do they call them like there was like a
name for those type of notes Corell
notes or some [__] I think it is Cornell
not Corell notes see know I don't
understand what the [__] how going to
tell me how to remember [__] like [__]
you fold it and then you're supposed to
Cate I can I can barely be my own
handwriting like that not going to help
me mhm I would just like for most for
the most part it's just a pressure would
save me i' like uh in class I would try
to like pay attention to some parts here
and there but if I got distracted I got
distracted if I fell asleep [__] it you
know but when it came time to do the
work or do a test I'd hope I could cheat
or look at somebody else's but if not i'
just be like okay like let me remember
some key points here Magna Carta
oh 1512 or 1215 I know it's one of those
it's probably 1512 1512 yeah you know
what who knows I was like I was talking
to a high school kid at this dinner at
this birthday party I was that the other
day he also has a high school child not
just because Marty's I was just school
kid no I was like trying to not be
antisocial so I'm like I went further
than two sentences with this kid sitting
next to me and it's like you realize
like oh these kids are there's some kids
that are [__] smart they're in there
actually learning [__] and paying
attention
I tried to scratch the surface with some
like knowledge to this kid and he went
down this [__] rabbit hole about
human history and geography and all this
[__] I I swear to God it was so hard not
to burst out laughing he was so [__]
you were just like Nazis are bad he was
like actually actually Guatemala took a
lot in [__] I don't remember anything
but I I drew my Hitler report thing I
had to draw a picture and I this a story
I left it at a McDonald's I was drunk
and I was on Saturday I left my whole
bag my report at McDonald's I had to go
back like I left something what is it
it's a picture of Hillary I drew and
then that was crazy we talked about it
but that was wild to go back just like
we we have it but can never come back
here I slept there on Saturdays cuz we
get drunk on my homies mom's a paramedic
get out by 600 fall asleep McDonald's 2
hours walk all the way home every
weekend system bro we clean up at 5:00
out of the house by 6 she's home at 6:30
this is uh in in your little town next
to Fresno yeah the one yeah Merced the
little sh towns yeah yeah it's just like
McDonald's and Merced come take a nap
huh yeah well I mean there homeless FS
taking a nap why can't I take a nap I'm
buying power Aid at least it's a fair
point it is a fair point sorry we got
way off topic the McDonald's employees
kicking out the homeless guy and
homeless guy like he stays like that guy
has a home he's just not there right now
and look he's got McChicken yeah he's
choosing to sleep here right now he's
here by choice I I I've once woken up
with like it's it's now 10:00 and
there's a family just eating like damn
dude I feel like a delinquent here stick
like Mad Dogs mhm and Coronas it's a
different crowd in the morning in
McDonald's it's just like a [__]
nursing home yeah the beginning of and
it's always Howard Fool's up at 4:30
like dressed ready to go awake at 6 at
McDonald's I don't get it I remember one
time I ate a bunch of mushroom gummies
before going in the airport and I
started tripping really bad and I kept
thinking like if I see a kid like I'm
going to die I'm going to go home I
can't take the guilt of being like hi in
front of a kid like I was tripping hard
man I was tripping hard but lucky I
didn't see a kid I just kept my head
down I was like I was freaking out you
skip your head straight down the airport
yeah cuz I was I was sitting down at the
gate and there's a big picture of like
an airplane and I was hallucinating
pretty hard I was just staring at it you
know like the [__] planes moving the
patterns are moving or whatever um but
then there was like an overwhelming
amount of people and I've been on
mushrooms before where I'm like I can
handle people being around but sometime
Sometimes some trips I just can't
sometimes it's just overwhelming like
[__] sentory overload you want to
call it so I started like freaking out
and then I caught
myself like freaking out I'm like yo
people were probably staring at me right
now like [__] and so I just put my
headphones on and I put like mellow
music and I just kept my head down I'm
like man the call is on the plane any
second now and luckily so this was like
a Southwest flight and I had paid extra
to get that business select which it's
not first class but at least you gone
before the other the other presents yeah
you're like number one peasant exactly
and so I I I was able to get on like in
the first group
and uh I I just sat down and I just
[__] put my headphones on I kept my
head down again and I just couldn't wait
for them to take off and as soon as they
took off they turned the lights off and
oh the trip was like Smooth after that I
was like hell yeah you falling asleep on
mushrooms n that's impossible for me bro
I've only fallen asleep on mushrooms
once and it was like a micro dose and it
did give me like trippy dreams I kept
having dreams where I'd like flashback
to like earlier in the year and then I'm
like oh [__] like I've been here the
whole time like I was dreaming like I I
I fell asleep on like a micro doose and
I felt like the mushrooms never kicked
in I was waiting for it to kick in I
knocked out I was already like pretty
exhausted and I had a dream that I was
at the airport in
Canada um where on this couch they had
these couches I think is in like
Edmonton in the airport or no I had a
layover I can't remember I just I was in
Canada in airport sleeping on a couch
and in my dream I like woke up on that
couch and it felt so real I'm like yo
what the [__] I'm like I'm tripping yeah
I'm like I'm tripping like what the [__]
and then and then I'd like snap out of
that and wake up from that but then I'd
be like in another dream and I was at
the hotel that I fell asleep at but I
was like in the lobby and I was like
what the [__] I was chilling in the
lobby like oh man sometimes when I'm my
shrooms I do walk around the hotels that
I'm at CU I like to trip at hotels
patterns and [__] you know they got
paintings on the floor and [__] yeah I
got so I'm like oh [__] like almost
almost just been chilling in the lobby
the whole time and then I like snap out
of that and then I'm like actually awake
now and I'm like what the [__] it's like
7:00 a.m.
already that's a layered trip I don't
think I can handle that one you like the
dream in the dream in the dream the
worst one man this is like the scariest
Inception trips [__] up trip I ever
had way like close to like N9 or 10
grams of of like mixed strains we're in
Seattle and this guy he has like a lab
also I don't want to like make the guy
seem bad he wasn't like take all these
you'll be fine like he he gave he gifted
me shrooms and he told me straight up
like you better respect my mushrooms
like you better take small doses or
whatever I think his lab is called like
Seattle astronautics or something it's
like a
Spaceman and we ate like a we bro me and
my buddies we've never carried a scale
with us we we've eaten mushrooms like
we've we've been going out of town every
weekend since like last year October
it's like a year
now and out of like 20 something trips
I don't think we've never once used the
scale we just kind eyeball it you know
and sometimes you get a perfect amount
sometimes it's not enough but a lot of
times just like bro I [__] up and man
we we ate some uh albino penis envy some
baby shrooms it wouldn't kick in we ate
some of the other strand it's like an
hour and a half had passed nothing would
kick in we ate some of the candy bars he
had given us his little pill form he had
given us like nothing would kick in and
then man then it just hit like heavy
uh laughing a lot I'm hallucinating
heavy like my everything in my vision is
just
pixelated um then I then I was like
laughing so hard and then it turns from
a laugh to like a cry and then I was
just like Angry like swinging in the air
and this is this is the second time that
I've tripped so hard I started doing
like animal behavior the first time I
was like bouncing around like a monkey
but this time I just started doing like
a bull I think I was just really
frustrated at that time in my life like
angry and I just started like doing the
bull kick kick on the ground and I
started punching the couch and [__] and
my buddy came to like stop me cuz cuz
he's noticing like yo he's [__]
tripping and and when I saw his face and
him just walking towards me I like stood
up I was like no I'm good I'm good and
like I snapped out of it for like a
second but then I started like blacking
out and like I I couldn't stop seeing
like [__] visual patterns like even
if if my eyes were open or closed like I
couldn't see what's in front of me I
just saw [__] patterns then I black
out again then I was like stuck in my
own brain I kept trying to down 911 but
but I was like it felt like there was
like three of me inside arguing for like
control of my body bro like and I would
die like 91 and then I'd be like nah
stop being a little [__] like you're
just on drugs and I black out and at one
point I I just remember coming too and
and the hotel rooms like just spinning
and moving you know just like pixelated
and I couldn't for the life of me this
is where it got like the scariest for
the life of me I could not figure out
how I got to that hotel room where in
the world I was how long I've been in
that hotel room like what I do for a
living like oh you lost your name I lost
everything I've done that I've lost my
name in face so you got bad yeah and
then I just kept thinking I I started to
remember people like loved ones and [__]
and the other voice in my head would be
like nope like you made all those people
up you've been in this hotel room since
like the dawn of time this is the only
space that exists you made everything up
so that you keep yourself from being
bored the last 20s something years and
then I was like arguing myself like no
like I love these people I know they're
real and there's like nope like only way
out here is you got to kill yourself
like that's the only way and I was like
n like I know those people are real I
know they have to be real I started
yelling out their names in in the hotel
I started yelling out like loved ones
and [__] and then I kept thinking about
dialing 911 again and then I convinced
myself I'm like bro this is not even
real I was like this is uh I was like
I'm like the crackheads you see on the
street right now yelling and and the
this hotel room is in my head like I'm
stuck in my own imagination like and
then and then I'd be like no like like I
think the actual me would just be like
shut the [__] up like shut the [__] up
lay down like you're on drugs like shut
the [__] up but yeah I kept watching my
body do [__] that I was not in control
of like I I destroyed that hotel room i'
take random [__] and just throw it in
the restroom and like I'm watching my
body do it but I don't have control of
it like I'm not telling myself to
actually do this [__] there's no reason
like when I have really bad
trips uh what saves me is like a hot
shower with some like chill music and
and when I finally started to like snap
out of it like at [__] 6:00 in the
morning the trip started around like
midnight it's like 5:00 600 in the
morning I would get little glimpses cuz
you know as it's as it's coming on as
it's wearing off it's kind of like in
waves so I would get little glimpses of
like soberness and i' I not all the way
sober but sober enough to where I can
walk to the shower and want to turn it
on but I bro like I could not for the
life of me you could had a gun to my
head I could not figure out how to turn
the
faucet and then and then I and then i' l
lose control again and just start doing
random [__] again just [__] chunking
my buddy was Shing the room with me I
don't know where he was at though I just
like took his clothes out the [__]
luggage and my clothes out of my luggage
and like just making a mess it was
[__] nut is that like your standard
bad trip kind of activity or is that
just like nah that was just like I lost
control bro I thought I thought I wasn't
even going to come back from it I was
like that's it I'm like a [__] one of
those dudes now yeah I'm like I'm a
crack it on the street like that's the
only way that's the only place I I'll
end up sounds horrible yo I just checked
in off bar 3 hours later yo [__] come
help me bro this was screaming in this
room when I when I sobered up I was like
bro [__] I'm never going to do that
again eventually like a few weeks later
I did like a little bit you know and I
had a good trip again and I just told
myself like never [__] so much eat
that much again like there I guess I
just wanted to know what it was like
some but that [__] you know curiosity
killed the cat like I'm glad I didn't go
any further I'm glad nobody caught the
cops I do remember like bro there was it
got worse like I could tell I could tell
you for hours all the [__] I did but
there were times where I was being so
loud in there that people were banging
on the walls to shut up and I kept
thinking it was like voices and [__] but
I'm like once I snapped out of it and I
remember that people were banging on the
walls I'm like what if somebody called
the cops what if I caught the cops like
that would have sucked bro you would
whatever following I have on Instagram
they would have found out they would
have been like oh [__] he's [__] up or
he lost his mind or something you know
like nobody would ever got the real
story at least a straight story m you
know what I mean yeah I that was that
was I know it was bad but that was the
funnest mushroom story I've heard all
time man I was in there with you right
there that was wild I I've most I've
ever eaten was seven or eight so nine or
10 where I were I were you're I can't
I've never gotten to where I don't see
that's why we're just pixelates over my
eyes nah yeah n not only did it pixelate
I could still at least see like kind of
where I'm at but it got to a point where
like it went black and it uh you know
what it reminds me of on the [__] in
monitor when the music would play on a
computer and you just watching the
monitor do like light patterns like that
like it's just black it's just like
tunnels and patterns and tunnels more
tunnels than anything that sounds sick
yeah s that sounds that sounds was that
cool or was that kind of scary N I got
scary because uh I don't know I don't
know about you guys but when I'm
tripping and I'm seeing patterns move
after a while it's like my brain gets
tired of it 100% so it it was like
[__] exhausted like my brain couldn't
take it anymore it was just like a close
your eyes cuz it's there too yeah it was
like [__] bro I just wanted to die
like I just like [__] stop it like
[__] stop already and the thoughts
too you know just thoughts and thoughts
and loops and loops and Loops you got
looped in on three Personalities in your
own brain talking to each other bro I
was I was in scary man I was in there
yelling at like three versions of myself
like shut the [__] up being a little
[__]
[__] I'm going to sorry but the
funniest thing take away I've said it
many times stop being little [__]
you're just on drugs what you said I've
screamed at myself many times in
bathrooms
yo that was intense man s we don't ever
get crazy I mean we we've had a a a
mushroom expert dude on here and he
talks about lemonex and grinding this
and doing this and all this that sounded
wow bro you're eating schmor Sports of
[__] mushroom when did you go to
sleep like how did this end I fell
asleep
around like 10 like 7 8 a.m. oh you went
right to sleep after like the minute
they wore off you know I think my brain
was just so fried I just like oh man
waking up after you pass off off the
mushrooms I'm always up at like 4:00 in
the afternoon my day is gone I'm like
did you have to perform yeah yeah the
next day I perform oh yeah and it it was
it wasn't even that good of a
performance I just wanted to like your
brain's still gone yeah bro like I just
wanted to like I talked about the trip a
little bit like on stage cuz I felt like
I didn't want to just force jokes I
didn't I wasn't feeling it too much so I
did like the jokes or whatever but then
I ended up just kind of talking about
mushrooms and I try to keep it light I
told some good mushroom stories told
some bad ones and then I'm just like
anyway like I don't know you do
mushrooms now like let me know how I
went for
you yeah I I've uh We've did of the the
research and I keep seeing it over and
over and over the shiest comedian it
says yeah man I going talk to people
outside I'm it's not that I'm happy to
hear that but the past three weeks
that's all we've been talking about
trying to work through that same I don't
do [__] like I feel the same way like oh
if I'm not working with you I'm going to
go to the grocery store you're not going
to even hear me f check out I'm home
yeah you'll never know I exist halfth a
least resistance through life 100% like
I'm going to talk to two people and you
know who they are the cashiers I'm back
home and that's it I'm trying to break
out of it like him hey kid oh you made
me feel stupid [__] and I went when you
said that you wanted to do more than two
sentences I was like to me two sentences
are good that's a lot I'm like we had a
lot of progress today a lot told that
[__] two sentences you know like oh I
was telling my I lie to everybody what
do you do for uh marketing stuff have a
good day cuz I want people to talk I
just watched Good Fellas and realize
that's how Rota was it's all you
construction
[Laughter]
un what's up guys taking a quick break
from the episode to talk about one of
our brand new sponsors and this is
Hamilton devices before we even get
started go to Hamilton devices.com if
you check out with our code dope as
usual that's going to get you 15% off of
this right here this is the jet stream
this is a self-propelling battery it
shoots all the vapor from the cart for
you this right here will allow you to
smoke three carts at once and yes it's a
glass top it has a carb this is
essentially a rig on the go for your
Vapes and yes it is 510 threads for
everyone asking what the size is yes
it's universals 510 we have three dopest
carts in here there's three different
flavors going on at Once In The Box it
comes with dummy plugs that way you can
plug them up some none of us don't want
to hit all three at once it comes the
battery a couple O-rings a charger
everything you could possibly need to
charge this in maintenance is in this
box go to Hamilton devices.com and use
our code at checkout dope as usual all
one word
now you can smoke three carts on the go
if you're a
monster shout out to Hamilton
devices what's up guys taking a moment
from this awesome episode to talk about
one of our brand new sponsors this is
raw papers if you didn't know raw papers
is the official paper of the dope as
usual podcast first off shout out to
them for believing in the show thank you
very much so what you got to do is go to
your local head shop your local smoke
shop and get raw papers there but if you
go to the shop and you notice it's not
there tell them to reup go buy more
stuff go to hbi International if you're
a store and you want to check out
wholesale hemp composite plastic
Grinders yes they're plastic but it's
made from hemp kind of like chich and
Chong where the whole car is made of
weed same concept raw has so much more
than papers there's every single smoking
thing you can think of when it comes to
Rolling that got up next this is the
first paper I fell in love with this is
what I rolled through Instagram the very
first 3 years was kingside Supremes and
then as everyone knows the cone these
are gigantic boxes of raw cones if you
can't roll they have rollers and they
have cones so remember go to
rawthentic.com every single product they
have the information they have
everything if you want to donate you
want to do charity thank you so much to
raw papers for sponsoring the dope as
usual podcast back to the episode I
still tell people I'm a barber like I
just cut hair yeah
I used to cut hair oh you were a barber
for real yeah oh okay no sh during the
pandemic like uh you can cut yourself up
I didn't I I didn't cut myself up but I
did make a lot of money during the
pandemic this might make me a bad
citizen I don't know if people are going
to like get mad but I was definitely
like on some Speak Easy I felt like I
was like Holocaust hiding Jewish people
in my house like but for haircuts yeah
like you look scruffy the neighbors
started noticing and they' be like they
started [__]
hutsy
they would start coming to my doorbell
and like moms were like old guys would
just be like hey like you cut hair right
like you think you cut my son I'm just
like I don't know what you're talking
about like go back I can't take it
anymore this was Harry
Tubman he had a speaky Barber yo that's
right no one was cutting hair at all cuz
I cut I was cutting myself up in the
mirror yeah some Barbers were but it was
it was very much like Hush Hush you know
what I mean like all right one one
client at a time you got to space them
out so you make sure there's not too
many cars parked outside you know like
trug dealing I almost felt like that
I'll be like look bro you get here at
1:00 and you leave at 2:00 but you get
here at 1 cuz I have my next guy com in
like at 2:30 just to give us some
SpaceTime and I cannot have that guy
showing up early being a good customer
showing up at [__] 2:10 and you show
up late to your appointment at [__]
1:30 and now you guys are crossing or
whatever like if you if you're like more
than 5 10 minutes late I'm like we're
not doing it we're not risking it bad
yeah I wasn't going to risk it you got
to be careful man my mom does Nails
that's what she does so she I mean I
don't even think she was doing nails
during that [__] no I didn't care bro I
didn't even think about it no I didn't
even think about it cuz fools were
looking bad during the pandemic I caught
Co like three times that year oh [__]
yeah I was still doing stand up comedy
say it I caught Co three times that year
but but I tell you what I made a lot of
money couldn't hear and I made a lot of
progress in comedy there weren't a lot
of comics wanting to work and we you
know I was in Texas I was in Dallas
Texas Texas we're one of the probably
the first one of the first clubs to open
so I was [__] steady doing comedy
cutting hair for whoever wanted it so it
didn't really like how deep into your
career in comedy were you at that point
I was still very much an open micer I
had early in that year in February I had
done a festival called the HW Comedy
Festival and they like taped me and they
were going to put me on HBO and all this
stuff but then they they didn't put me
on the the main guy ended up not liking
me he would like like me to my face and
then later on be like nah n nah so like
hold on you were an open micer 3 years
ago and now you're about to have a
Netflix special yeah that's unheard of I
don't know
maybe [__] them hell no Marty Marty's
background imagine that
fuckingn a horn going up Marty's working
with all the biggest ComEd you can think
of bro he helped run all their shows all
their stuff so like he knows what it's
like to get that special you've been
there yeah I land I landed that Festival
it's like a Latino Comedy Festival kind
of just just by chance man they they
were like submitting tapes to get into
that Festival but I had no idea the
Addison Improv hit me up the the manager
at that time called me like on a like
just random like last minute he was like
hey man there's a there's a showcase at
the club at 5: p.m. this Saturday do you
want to be on and I was just like yeah I
always took stage time so I like hey
yeah let's go I didn't know what it was
for and it turned out to be like an
audition for that Festival there was
like six people in the audience so the
guy who's is's like Rick something weird
ass guy he was like running the festival
though he uh he was like Hey man y'all
as comic support each other y go sit in
the audience until it's your turn to go
up oh [__] like [__] it now there's 16
people in the audience you know 10 of us
comics and we go up whatever and he
liked my set he was like yeah I like it
you know it's clean cuz I would hardly
ever do dirty jokes or or cuss and [__]
um not that I'm like against it but just
whatever you know and it put me in the
festival and uh yeah the festival I got
to meet like Angela Johnson his whoa
whole bunch of big Comics man and they
they they ended up lending a lot of
Helping Hands later on you know these
past couple years um so the festival
definitely helped me a ton bro it helped
me a ton I cannot tell you how much
Angela Johnson and his trof helped me I
didn't make it on HBO which was like
whatever bro I had only been doing it
like for a little bit at that time yeah
like two three years or whatever um but
I do remember feeling like after after
the festival was over like going home
was like
from here bro just nothing but up like
things are about to take off you know
and then the [__] pandemic happened
like [__] heard that so much literally
literally two weeks later just like NOP
like nobody's going nowhere I was like
ah [__] that hurts so bad yeah but
that's why anytime any any shows opened
up during the pandemic I was like I'm on
I'm on [__] it If I die I die Chasing
the Dream yeah [__] yeah you're doing
what you like to do and not many people
get to make a living doing what they
like to do yeah you know what I'm saying
and were cutting hair three four years
ago okay I was cutting hair up to a year
ago this month no [__] yeah
nice hell yeah I mean you're on like
Stadium stages with like B cut hair and
[__] I love it that's a real real ethic
right there oh speaking of some Mexican
[__] cuz we always talk about like
that's that's some real Mexican [__]
you're working all right cool when you
started popping which one of your
cousins started hating on you first um
I'm sorry because it it's is everything
it's like which one which one is going
to be it cuz you know exactly what I
mean yeah n um I I think honestly I
don't I can't I mean I could name a few
that I know for sure are haters but I
think the ones that were already hating
on me for the way I am with them were
the same ones that are like just kept
hating maybe we're doing that whole fake
like we got to hang out I was just like
bro you did you did not want to hang out
a few months ago like I feel you go back
to Hayden you know what I mean is your
family supportive overall um the main
ones that I was already like close to
cuz I I'm I mean I grew up at my
grandma's I was very like I see some
family um the family that I'm close to
right now is the ones that I've probably
always been close to you know what I
mean so I just stick with them like like
I said I've never been like super social
and [__] even with like blood relatives
I'm like even just cuz we're related
doesn't mean I'm going to like put an
effort to like hang out with you and I
don't think it's an effort it's it's
more like if you agree with me I don't
know if you're the same but it's more of
like
a I'd rather just be here
yeah that's it that's all it really like
I'd rather just not yeah bro like I I
love I love my relatives I love my
friends or whatever but come over here
yeah come here yeah and there there's
only so much I can like take of certain
people
like I would love to like see my family
more often but I'm literally faced with
the choice um at least once every few
months if like if I get a free weekend
it's like do you want to go spend time
with family or you want to get some
[__] work in it's like I want to go
do comedy like I want to go put some
work in like the family that I that I
really am close with like I see them
enough I feel maybe I maybe I could see
a little more like I'm a dad I got a
four-year-old son I see him more than
anybody and people do like I do have
like relatives be like well we want to
see him we want to see him and I
probably should prioritize like hey you
know these people these are relatives
that want a relationship with my son but
at the same time I'm just like you're
building right now as long as I'm seeing
my son like [__] yeah I see him later
yeah but you're building dude like the
there's only a small window of time
where you're like I feel like I can
crush the world right now and I am yeah
strike while IR hot Bro [__] Yeah that
and you're so you're 26 right yeah I
just turned 27 Oh when's your birthday
October 3rd oh all right happy happy
birthday man thank you thank you all
right so bro you're young as [__] this
is the time you know what I mean like
these next 10 years are you're I'm not
sleeping I'm just working everything I
got a weekend off I'm just trying to go
work yeah cuz why wouldn't you bro I
feel like if the day the one day you let
off it's like I went up three steps I
let off one day I went back four the
[__] D you ever see that movie uh inter
Stell yeah where that fool's just like
kind of there for the whole movie to
stand by himself and [__] I think that's
the one right no no no you're talking
about like uh Matt D or something I'm
mat Damon okay I'm I'm I'm Matthew MCC I
haven't seen it uh it's like 2028 or
2030 or something like I don't remember
the exact year it's in the future
and the world can't like produce good
soil anymore so they can't like grow
crops so like a lot of people are going
hungry it's kind of like going towards
the end
times and it's like bro like what if one
day my soil just doesn't grow good food
anymore cuz on that thing I think on
inell like the the main thing they can
grow is corn and the whole world is like
tired of corn that's how they can get it
one day what if all I can do is grow
corn right now I'm going enjoy the [__]
out of the soil I'm going Harvest like a
[__] you know what I mean got to
take advantage that's a good way to put
it man I like it just it's it's just the
mentality of like what do you want to do
like I I could just do it myself and
keep working or I can go see my family
what about Christmas I'll see you on
Christmas yeah I feel I'll see them
enough bro yeah no I I feel that's just
kind of the way it goes man especially
when you're working and you're you're
working for yourself like you're you're
a comedian it's not like you're on a
football team and [__] yeah you know
yeah you are the business yeah no for
real um so you have a four-year-old son
you said mhm so when you're 2 damn you
were you were just starting out comedy
essentially right I was like 22 when he
was born I think I was like
22 um and it's really what made me kick
comedy into the next gear
because before that I was I was living
at my grandma I was making like couple
hundred bucks a week man I I had a
shitty little car I was just doing open
mics and showcases every night and it
was satisfying you know what I mean I
had no I had no drive to like actually
get my barber license I would go to
Barber College like when I felt like it
cuz I I just like pay as you go type
[__] yeah I'd go get some hours I'd [__]
around with my friends whatever um but
then I once once you know I had my son I
was like
man I don't want to be in the nin to-5
thing you know I want to really make
comedy work and so I felt like I had to
really get serious about like how to get
better gigs how to how to become a
full-time comic like we're it's it's a
long-term goal and I had to figure out
how to get there and I had to take it so
serious once I had my son in my mind I
was like I don't want him to by the time
he's going to school I need to be able
to have him living in a better
neighborhood with better schools
something more decent you know I need to
be driving something respectable safer
for him and I just I need him to be
comfortable he doesn't have to be rich
but I need him to be comfortable I need
to I need him to be comfortable and I
don't want to do it I don't want to
provide that with the job I hate or with
because I'm like I don't want to get
stuck in a 9 to5 cuz I know myself I I
you know all these 9 to5 jobs I had they
drive me nuts like like after two weeks
I I quit I never had a job for more than
a couple weeks and every job I've really
had is just like a favor somebody hires
me as a favor like I couldn't even get
past the [__] I've never had like an
interview at a real job no he's always
like yeah let me work with you yeah like
I app at places I never [__] have
gotten like the interview it's always
somebody me up with a job like just gets
me in so I was like [__] it like I still
cut in hair you know you got to provide
but I was just like anytime I have a
chance to do a show that could lead to
something bigger any any chance I have
to do any show like I'mma [__] take
it I'm going ride as much as I can
anytime I have to spend away from my son
I'm going to make sure it's productive
and [__] thankfully so far you know
it's worked out like we're we're in a
we're uh we're living out where my dad
is at now and it's it's a way better
School District uh he's comfortable me
uh his mom and I we not together but we
we get along like we're cool and I'm I'm
able to help her be comfortable like
that's all I really wanted is to be able
to do I say all I wanted like it's it's
a little it's not a little but that's
what I really wanted was for us to be
comfortable and for me to be able to
provide doing my dream smashed that goal
that you started to do and now you're
must be starting to think about was that
next like now I'm trying to think of
like yeah like the ne like longevity of
this like I'm not that smart with money
I'll be honest I'm very
immature um but I do try to focus
on making sure I make
moves and working to always be able to
create the money to to create income you
know what I mean it's one thing to like
you know money is important right don't
get me wrong but the only thing more
important than money is the ability to
make it how you make it so like maybe
I'm not being so smart with the [__] I'm
producing in this Factory but I'm I'm
trying to be as smart as I can with like
how this Factory runs like make sure
this [__] Factory is operational yeah
you're high value in what you do yeah
and eventually I I'll I'll save enough
money to just [__] disappear [__] it
sick don't let any Comics make you feel
bad that you went warp speed past to the
front of the line of this [__] cuz I
mean the internet changed that whole it
takes a decade to get good at this [__]
and deserve a special like that ain't it
no no not working like [__] crazy you
build your own fan base and you not then
Netflix comes to you if you're not that
good You' been do 20 years doesn't mean
you deserve [__] like I know a lot of
bad cooks yeah I've put in my my fair
share of work I know I know it's a
different set of difficulties in like
the comics in the past had or whatever
they have the internet yeah but like
it's not like I'm uploading only crowd
workor or something like I'm uploading
bits like I wrote These and and I have
to burn them and I'm not I'm not
like whatever I upload online whatever
whatever jokes I put online if I put an
hour worth of jokes online I might use
like five minutes of those on my stage
now but like really bro like I try not
to use anything that's already online
that way when you when you see me online
when you see me on stage it's totally
different I don't want people to think
like okay well he's just doing what he
does online like we like it but I'm
satisfied don't need to see a show again
no I want them to be like damn he did
something different hopefully the next
time he comes he also does more
different though more inclined to come
keep checking out the shows yeah for
sure so how you liking this traveling
cuz you're you're you're going
everywhere how you dealing with as
someone that doesn't like to be around
people man currently on a world tour or
just nah not like a world tour I just
been across the States you I like
traveling it's cool uh the first after
the first few months I like hated it for
a bit and then I liked it again now I
feel like the airport is the airport and
the hotel room is like it can be be the
shittiest place to be or like the best
place to be because I feel like there's
my personal life my home life and then
there's the comic life and there two way
different you know when I'm when I'm
having too much fun away from home I
feel guilty that I miss home and when
I'm when I'm too comfortable at home I'm
like [__] I should really be working but
when I'm at like the airport or like a
hotel it just feels like a Purgatory
like in the middle and it feels like I
can be alone with my thoughts a little
bit so I don't know everywhere you're at
there's something to like enjoy or stay
productive do you trip on stage ever n
I've done it a few times like my first
time performing at the Hollywood improv
we were there for like a week and uh man
I do I do feel a lot of pressure even
though I try to like ignore to try not
to I still do things like under pressure
where like there was all these people
coming out that's how I got the Netflix
deal actually was doing a week of shows
at the Hollywood improv really yeah my
representation invited out like a lot of
Industry people like Amazon Netflix and
people from this production company or
whatever
and um one of the
nights I love my manager to death I hope
he doesn't hear this and think I'm just
like trying to talk [__] about my
manager is dope bro like that dude knows
me I feel like so far he's looked out
for me in like the best way but he kept
telling me that like his boss the head
of the best you know the big manager at
his company or whatever was going to be
there which happens to be uh George
Lopez's manager he's like yeah he wants
to check you out he wants to check you
out with her and on that show before the
show I was already just I don't know I
was just anxing what ate a bunch of
mushrooms and I was just on stage
tripping balls and it was funny I might
have [__] up a couple parts and there
were a couple parts of the show where I
felt like oh my God everybody's looking
at me and they they they feel bad for me
they think I'm like some drug addict but
for the most part it was just like funny
and after the show all my friends were
like damn bro like you were active like
you you having a badass set I was like
dancing around and [__] um and at the
end of the show I like chugged a few
beers and now y that are like I'm so
Ohio on mushrooms oh
no do good like it off you're a comic
this type of
[__] yes that was yeah that was in my
mind like welcome to my show like I
don't care whose manager you are you're
at my show yeah yeah the guy was still
cool yeah he came up there he said
what's up what he was like yeah cuz I
mean obviously we all saw the little
[__] that happened with you and
George Lopez which is hilarious bro but
uh I mean I'm sure it's been beat to
death and people ask you about it 900
times but yeah I I saw it I saw it um it
is what it is man the only thing the the
only thing I say now is like like George
I don't I don't have no problem with
George Lopez himself um it just does
kind of suck that like I feel like I put
a lot of work and effort I'll talk about
being Hispanic on stage from time to
time you know I try not to make my whole
set about it if anything I make it like
maybe 5 10% of my sh I don't know but I
try to just write write jokes that are
unique to me and also relatable to like
the majority of people you I want I want
everybody to think I'm funny you know
like I'm proud to make my people proud
you know I'm proud to be hispanic
Mexican Latino but I would like for
everybody to think it's funny you me be
on like a whole other level that's what
fluffy was saying yeah
so even as an open micer people were
always like oh yeah you're going to be
the next George Lopez and I'm like why
is that the first comic you go because
you're Mexican yeah that's all they're
saying so I'm trying my best for years
to not be associated with George Lopez
with my jokes with everything you know
and then George Lopez goes on and says
that and it's like [__] now I have no
choice but to be Associated like it's
like if I'm trying so hard not to walk
in dog [__] and I'm I'm staring at this
dog [__] so much that I accidentally
stepped in this dog [__] like somebody
just threw the dog [__] at me it's like
God damn it I for everywhere I go even
if not everybody smells it I'll have the
slightest hint of dog [__] on my shoe
for the rest of my career yo we met we
met an hour ago
I use dog [__] as references all the
[__] time so when you stand like you
just [__] steeping dog [__] I said
that [__] yesterday two days ago I like
the way this is gone yeah you're always
going to smell a little bit but it's
like also it's like are you I think
you're fine I think you're fine just cuz
like you know I I I
saw I was just hating it's all good it's
okay sometimes people [__] up to me it
felt like the world kind of responded
like damn that's some hating ass [__]
what's wrong with you yeah and that was
cool that people were like having my
back you know what yeah when you're
genuine just you I'm sure when you saw
you went you [__] jerk well go back
to do what I was doing anyway because
it's like at the end of the day I'm not
going to sit here and cubba Gooden Jr
swing and [__] boys in the hood cry
like but I also agree with what he was
saying on that podcast George Lopez I
think they wanted on that podcast I
believe it was they were telling him
that he should apologize to like Paul
Rodriguez for for a bunch of [__] that
he spoke to him or about him and George
was like nah I shouldn't if I if I
remember correctly he was saying
something like nah I shouldn't apologize
cuz I mean we're comics on the podcast
just shooting the [__] like what and I
agree with that too like shoot the [__]
man he apologize which I appreciate a
lot don't get me wrong but I was like
man like you didn't have to let these
people bully into apologizing
apologizing [__] it but better post that
black Square on your Instagram but I do
I do like that he did it like [__]
like privately like cuz I don't think he
did it for people I think he did it out
of like he just hit you up there yeah he
hit me up he called me he's just like no
and I told him he didn't have to he's
like nah man he's like I want to I was
like I appreciate it so I like that was
cool you know yeah that's cool man it's
a good way to end it all I imagine is
this fool just jumping into frame that
that
man that's all I ever think of the man
has been in in this [__] industry for
[__] years and years like there's got
to be so much [__] that that he's had to
deal with that pisses him off to get to
that point you know what I mean like
100% dude it's like the meeting reach at
going I'm a year into comedy bro I'm a
year into comedy and I'm still like on
the beginner level and then I see like
Adam Sandler and I'm like how the [__]
is that dude still so nice that D so
nice to everybody like what the [__] I
think it's this and this the way you'll
never lose it you you could just be the
person going oh my God Adam Sandler or
you could just be Adam Sandler like you
know I'll take on this responsibility of
always taking a picture always saying hi
always smiling because that person they
don't know that you stepped in dog [__]
yeah they just like ad he was a [__]
[__] also it's like got to be cool
like not to be cocky or whatever but in
this industry we get paid pretty
handsomely yeah you know what I mean if
if a McDonald's
cashier has a pissy attitude to me when
I ask them for something extra or just
to be like I don't know like I get it
you make minimum wage like this job
sucks whatever but if I have that
McDonald's pissed off customer service
that sucks cuz I don't make McDonald's
wages you know what I mean thankfully
like by the grace of God like whatever
it is like thankfully so I should be
more appreciative like I make what I
make because of the people so I can't be
like that to the people like 5% of
comedians make earning like that you
know I mean like a lot of comedians do
earn that
McDonald you know it's bro I'm something
to be happy about doing exactly what I
wanted to do like this is my dream job
so like [__] I I should kick it cool I
don't know what my attitude is going to
be like when I'm George Lopez's age so I
can't then we come back we talking about
him in 35 years yo it's he time [__]
this called me flew over in his car and
[__] he apologized I'm like [__]
these new Comics bro he's a AI robot how
am I supposed to respect this fool you
know what I mean in 30 years he going to
be scary robots have feelings
too me too shiny robot you ever watch a
Futurama yeah um there's an episode
where they're watching Zoidberg at at
the open mic it's like the opening of
the episode but before zo zberg was his
robot it just the episode opens on on
the robot in the comedy club and he says
uh so I says super collider I just met
her it's got to be like the greatest
drest open m [__] zoyberg and Bender
make the show yeah hell yeah bro for
sure do I don't know if you remember I
remember when that show came out that
[__] [__] me up man I was a kid bro I
was yeah but I was a kid but I remember
when it came like the Simpsons but but
future yeah all right let's let's watch
this [__] for a minute that was a good
show man [__] hilarious man your
favorite three movies of all time oh
three three hold on but not comedies not
comedies cuz it's a whole another
category you can't okay not comedies
three a bronx tail nice
nice um heat with alucino Robert yeah
hell yeah I've never seen that oh and
the trunk of the car was about to blast
him blew my mind when I was a kid yeah
had wrapped up with plastic already cops
go by I blew my mind is it like another
loose variation of Good
Fellas no no it is sick as hell there's
no like you just got to watch it it's uh
alucino Robert DeNiro and I want to say
um man that
guy vmer that other guy too man he
recently passed away he has he has a
classic line in that movie where Robert
daero is basically letting the guys know
like uh he's like we can pull off one
more job get that money and [__]
retire where you guys can split split
ways now and just call it safe you know
what I mean whatever you have now just
call it cuz right now there's too much
heat on us you know [__] alucino is
watching us and shit's going south here
and there and uh that gu man I forget
the actor's name I feel so bad bro's
he's [__] badass in that movie he he
looks at uh he looks at Robert D's
character that guy's name is Neil he's
like you know Neil he's like you see for
me he's like the juice is the action or
something like that like I love it like
he just he's like I'm not I'm not
worried about money he tells him Robert
dero tells me he like nah Noah he's like
you got money invested in stocks and you
got Properties or like if I were you I'd
play smart I'd cut I'd cut it now he's
like nah like for me it is about the
juice I was like Dam that gu I get love
out here in
Harlem [__] right there they still love
me if you if you truly love some [__]
like you feel that bro that's I feel
with comedy I'm like hunt do it for free
I'll do [__] free right now I fly I'll
do 10 shows for free like it's just it
makes me hyped and there's not many
things that hype me cuz I'm like yo get
away from me go home so when I'm hyp I'm
like wow I can get hyped like normal
people like a Coca-Cola commercial and
[__] I'm hyped up and happy but um sorry
heat Bron Bronx tail heat heat Bronx
tail and damn which one these are not I
didn't expect any of these n no you're
I'm not saying cuz you're younger than
us you're eight years younger than us
basically 10 years yeah most people
don't really watch movies anymore man no
bro I'm like a movie fan bro same I love
movies I love a three-hour movie
I love that [__] but D it's tough I just
went to the movie Museum here in uh down
in uh by Hollywood I always wanted to
see that I just went like on Saturday
Sunday [__] was sick Bro um damn man
it's hard I kind of want to say I kind
of want to say that movie in stellor but
then I also kind of want to I got to
watch you the second person to bring the
movie up yeah that's a good movie never
seen it um but damn I don't know bro
that third that third spot that's a
that's a doozy what is this what's there
so there's a lot of movies out there see
when you take more than 10 seconds you
watch movies yeah no for real how about
if you had to pick if you if I had to
pick like three comedies I'd pick
uh Little Nikki
yes um hot rod
yeah and uh either super bad or or uh
Pineapple Express there both great super
bad came out the day I graduated high
school damn watching like wow our
pineapp pressed it sorry fle Express
that was hilarious man super bad we saw
it on YouTube my my older cousin um
while my mom would go to work sometimes
it was it was like one summer my grandma
was was living in Mexico for the summer
and me it was just me and my mom but my
mom would work all day so she dropped me
off at my older cousin's house and they
were talking about that movie uh him and
his friends and there was like no adult
supervision so I was maybe like 11 my
cousin they were like teenagers were so
they put on that movie and it's just
like the funniest [__] had ever seen bro
that [__] killed me the first time I
watched it it's just seemed Super Bad on
YouTube for the first time is crazy to
me yeah it was like bootle it was like
in Parts it was like oh [__] part one
through 28 yeah I watch a lot of movies
like that and then they'll take them
down [__] six weeks later it's over
bro one of the one of the clips was
missing we had to miss like a chunk of
the movie like part three out of 10 was
just
missing there's no blood on my
pants sleeping I remember catching it
catching it like on TV like years later
and it was just like parts that I had
never seen I was like oh [__] director's
cut which is actually just a regular yo
did you ever buy bootleg DVDs yeah hell
yeah we got the uh Passion of the Christ
on bootleg that's a crazy bootleg
skipped 30 40 minutes the second time I
watched it like yo this shit's brutal it
skipped from when they were lashing him
all the way up to the hill and I was
like yo this movie's not that bad
everybody's crying and [__] and then
when I watched the real version like I
missed an hour yo the worst thing ever
happened was a you ever seen precious no
I haven't seen that one I don't want to
[__] it up for you but I'm going to
watch it yeah don't foret I'm watch I
thought it was a comedy I had no idea I
I walked in on a funny part I didn't
know it was hilarious I don't think it
was supposed to be funny but I walked in
like damn this is hilarious and then
Mo'Nique went wild bro you got to okay
when I see that movie I'm going to text
you so you can tell me which part was
the hilarious I can't even I can't even
ruin it for you it's she's she's eating
something in Sprint in and I went what
that's
hilarious n it and I was like she's
sprinting this movie's getting nuts
that's the part I walked in thought
you're were watching
Norbit he's like Eddie Murphy does it
again
man yo Norbit's [__] up it's such a
sad moov it feels bad for him and I know
it's going to end up good and I still
feel bad for him at the beginning of
that movie wait I'm thinking of bow
finger what's one no no no that's that's
bow finger I haven't seen both both
fingers him and Steve Martin it's pretty
good okay it's pretty good um hot rod
man hot rod is good and my little
brother raised him on that [__] yeah
yeah I've been drinking greeting tea all
damn day you make me get the demons out
get the demons out of me yo I love
that's Danny McBride was first like kind
of introduced to me do you watch uh East
Mound and down hell yeah yeah what's do
you watch you've seen it all yeah what's
your favorite season um I whichever one
it was I don't know if it's my favorite
season but it's definitely like my
favorite episode I love that dude Stevie
and I and I cannot repeat the [__] he
said it's when he no no no no that's my
favorite scene um I do love I love a
couple of my favorite Parts is uh
there's one where where uh he starts
coaching the Little League team for
charity it's like a team it's like all
black kids and he's like you think uh
he's like you think I'm proud to come
from some pot wig wooden teeth
[__] and Stevie's like George
Washington didn't do [__] he can suck my
[__] dick I [__] [__] hate
that I remember
that he just goes
overboard just laugh I know exactly what
part he goes Stevie's my favorite [__]
is when they go to Mexico oh I love that
Blanca the whole time and then Stevie
comes in and I don't know but get shot
that's a good season man I I want to
watch it all over again I love how
stev's trying to track down uh dad Kenny
no st's trying to track down Kenny he
Bing that prostitute and the she just
like doesn't you only paid for an
hour that's how it starts that's the
beginning of the he starts questioning
her after like if he had to do that you
know bro that was like that's a good one
you take credit card I didn't know you
hoes take credit cards sorry you got to
watch these it is it's it's my third
it's my fourth favorite show Fourth
favorite so what are the first three uh
it's a tie between the officer Seinfeld
because Seinfield less people so it's
office is funniest [__] to me I love
that show office and Seinfield you said
tie between those two yeah it always
flipflops and then I go um It's Always
Sunny in Philadelphia I love that show
oh it's so good man that's number three
then number four is he's bring down and
number five is uh Kirby enthusiasm tied
with rest development you're a true
comedy lover I love rest development
that's such a good one that's one of the
best written shows I ever seen they'll
be three years later they bring a joke
from episode 5 you know what I mean
where that FS painted blue and then gold
[__] David Cross is funny as hell Tobias
Tobias fun you really watch it you don't
go nowhere you stay at home like me
watch it all day dude my buddy H over
there he got me into a lot of these
shows man as a true comedy fan yeah they
filmed Always Sunny uh the the season 15
right outside here uh the the the um
last I won't say it cuz you'll know
exactly what episode and people know
where it's at but we I saw the script
and it's like all right Danny De I'm
reading the script cuz it's through a
window and they have it all the posters
they had them all dressed and I saw
sweet D eating [__] sandwiches right
here at the car oh man man I called you
yeah I was here I have a Danny DeVito
when he's a the art dealer artist to
blogan I think I have it in a painting
and I left it by the front door I was
like I made to deal with the security
guard if he comes out here don't [__]
rush me cuz I'm going to rush this fool
and get him to sign it I waited all day
by the camera you got it you got it no
never saw it a broke my heart man he saw
you first he probably didn't he ducked
under a [__] car he's tiny but yeah
dude I love sometimes out of just like a
nervous habit like and and then I feel
[__] I feel so stupid and bad and
I'll go back but sometime I was like at
the mall I was like I was I was in New
York and the H&M Your Time Square is
like [__] three floors like got to go
to the third floor for the m and I was
just looking at this jacket and I seen
the I seen these two dudes like pointing
at me and I got their phone and I and I
could tell they about appr was like [__]
and I just left I just I just left my
friends there I just took off but then I
was like why did I do that like just say
hi to the guy and I went back up there
he didn't say nothing he probably was
just like wasn't even poting at he
probably point at somebody else behind
you look at the price it says it on here
but it's different just me just being a
dick like no dude I I feel what you're
saying because there' be some the only
time I remember like that cuz I meet a
lot of people is when you were like oh
my M I was on mushrooms at the Dodger
game and it started going bad not bad
but it started going
like uncomfortable I just want to go
home man I just want to be in my room
like watching something dope dark and
then I just started getting hit up by
fans on the way out and I just kept my
head down
I put a hat on I looked straight down
and didn't work I apologize to everybody
I'm so sorry my mushrooms I'm having
kind of a bad trip oh you want to take a
picture I'm very sorry I can't sit here
and talk I just kept walking and I just
H like five and then I met the same fan
like a year later in LA and he's like yo
you're a lot different on un sure like
oh you're the [__] dude in his
girlfri bro I I've taken pictures with
people and like I feel like I'm playing
a court with her and who knows if they
can tell or not right but what pisses me
off is that I've been sober and people
will freak me out just because three of
them like rush me
and then they they'll try to make some
like inside joke and be like that I'm
not even like catching up on maybe of a
joke I did like quo some [__] what like
big but it'll be a joke that I didn't
even remember I've uploaded before there
or something and they're so fast and I
don't react fast enough they're like ah
he's on mushrooms I'm like no I'm not
I'm just bombarded by three strangers
man like what the [__] I'm eating icy
bro yeah like he's so [__] Stone
right now like no I'm sober I'm 100%
sober
like now what what's your relationship
ship like with weed oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah thank you uh I haven't smoked in
like five or six months um even in the
in the later years like the last two
three years I had like slowed down and
another thing even when I was like heavy
even when I was at my heaviest like
smoking the most consistently I would
never smok and go on stage everybody
thinks I'm high on stage yeah I think my
I think my normal mentality like my
normal state of mind is just like comes
off High I've been on I've been high on
stage like I've been doing comedy since
like
2018 2017 something like that I've been
high on stage off
weed maybe four times on mushrooms maybe
three is it too much for you when you're
smoking n i just uh I just don't want to
I just want to stay in the moment yeah
and uh if if I don't usually do a lot of
crowd work but if something comes up and
people start yelling like I want to stay
kind of on top of itre um also was like
if I can't do it sober then I don't feel
like I'm really can do it you know no I
feel you um but I would still smoke like
right after the show like every night or
like just maybe throughout the day or
whatever here and there but for sure at
night like I was not going to I was not
going to go to bed over yeah um but if
my son was with me then I wouldn't smoke
and and I started being able to get my
son more so and I started to phase out
more once things started kind of taking
off for me though
there I feel like there's so much [__]
that I got to stay on top of that I just
did not feel comfortable smoking anymore
oh [__] that's why you stopped yeah I
get like just way too paranoid maybe
like I I as soon as I would be high I'd
enjoy it for like five minutes and then
I just be like [__] cuz you'd end up
meeting somebody who who maybe you
respect what you don't know how they
feel about weed smokers or some [__] I'm
just like [__] and then I kind of wanted
to be like well who cares you know who
cares what they think but I care a lot
about what people think I feel like
caring about what people think being a
people pleaser is my literal job
description yeah okay you're right
you're right you know what I'm saying so
like while some people may not care
about weed some people might and like I
just feel more comfortable coming at
people sober I feel like I'm coming at
you from just like a zero like level
like if I came at you drunk if I came at
you high I might be a little more easy
going but I might also not catch
everything I might not be as aware you
know what I mean sometimes I'm paranoid
that people are talking [__] to me and
I'm not aware of it maybe I'm not smart
enough to catch on or maybe they're
complimenting I'm not a maybe they're
trying to throw me a signal maybe
somebody's just giving me a heads up
subliminally like I want to be able to
just you watch Heat a lot yeah someone's
trying to give me someone to give me
heads up I'm just like well you're
acting like you're all chill and stuff
but you trained boxing though right I I
did that for a couple months boxing cuz
I cuz I liked it as a kid like as a kid
would meet up get the gloves on or
whatever um
I got I got real sick and I felt like I
was really out of shape like late March
April something like that and so uh me
and my sister I hang out with my my
younger sister a lot she's a teenager I
was like man we should go like join a
gym or some [__] we had talking about it
so one day when she got out of school I
was just like man come on let's go and
we just went gym to gym and we just did
it for a few months but uh once it got
closer to July and excuse me the Netflix
taping I just I didn't go back cuz I
mean I had other [__] to FOC hear me not
going to go be a boxer like but it I I
was getting like bad out of shape bro
like my body was just looking all funky
have you been seeing the Dylan danis
Logan Paul situation on Twitter at all
yo uh Dylan danis that's his name he's
the one that keeps like putting uh
Logan's girlfriend on blast he just
explained it all to me right now right
for here they're going to fight in two
days yeah bro I'm excited to see that
yeah I just want to know like I want to
see I want to see people really fight
like all the the YouTuber stuff and
stuff like cool I'm sick of box want to
see fools take the gloves off and go
nuts cuz that's when you know like L PA
really fight he murdered that guy well
that's that's what's fun about watching
like MMA bro it's like [__] throw a
kick you been in uh in person you ever
been to one nah I just went like two
weeks ago yeah it was an amateur one but
it made me feel bad hey can you eat
while you watch like hell yeah I was EA
a giant ass School cookie [__] remember
the on at school for 50 35 they were the
same ones I went and bought three over
the course of three hour yeah I'm going
to go to one of those on but I felt bad
I love MMA but watching Fool's fight in
person like I told you it was the guy's
first fight while you're sitting there
eating [__] that they can't even eat for
6 months out of their life you're at eye
level with them just with a cookie just
just with a jacket on you're like what
the [__] you doing up there yeah with my
phone I was like oh my God look at his
nose I feel bad because just judging his
mes like I wouldn't have done that
exactly exact like ass F can't even take
a hit look at his nose is split all you
do is hold oh God yo I saw someone get
kicked and then the sweat did that Rocky
[__] [__] hooked but I got I saw some
leg cakes and I just kind of like
cringed oh and then I saw Fool's nose
get split right yo who's that uh man
this was like a couple months ago
already there um there were two Mexican
fights that night but the undercard it
was a Mexican dude and a Brazilian dude
it was like uh what's his name like
Brandon what was that I
you talking about MMA or boxing MMA MMA
he knows all this [__] hold on hold on
hold on bro I got a I got a
[__] oh my God bro hold on hold on
what's his name there's a Mexican kid
right now that's like the youngest
fighter ever oh he's out I think he's
out of uh California right not him but
there was a guy let me see
UFC I think it was Brandon Moreno it was
Brandon Moreno yeah yeah uh Brandon
Moreno versus uh uh
Pantoja bro [__] watch that fight
Brandon Mareno versus Pantoja I got to
see that one uh while I was on birs tour
some of the guys are fans like Mark
Norman and and Big Jay put it on and we
got to watch it it had already passed so
it technically wasn't live it was like
an hour after we watched all cars that
[__] fight bro that was a
[__] fight like full there just
a full T like it was better than
watching the fights and the movies they
just [__] punching holding each other
kicking punching holding each other like
you bro like it could have gone either
way it could have been anybody's fight
like yeah he got back into it like a
couple months ago I used to watch it a
lot I I I'm never really even that much
into it but I I'll keep up here and
there with you you know what I mean I
just watching the uh Justin gy Gage gay
yeah he's one of my favorite Fighters
that fool hit so hard for being so small
I don't want every time I watch MMA I'm
like I think I could do that and then
someone gets busted I go I'm done
when Conor McGregor broke his leg I what
happened I took the skateboard Vlog
right off my board y I'm not skating I'm
not doing this going to the Bears cuz
we're supposed to go to the Bears
they're going to show me a kickflip like
I'm going to break my [__] leg did
you see all the controversy yesterday
with him because he's been granted I
don't know anything but what I think is
going on cuz usada you know who usada is
right usada is like the governing body
that piss tests all the fighters like
psychotically [__] the fighters are most
test athletes out of like all the
athletes they get like [__] micro
tested for PDS and [__] it's like they
smoke Nick Diaz his career came to an
end over weed with [__] usada like
it's a real issue I thought usada was a
person a governing agency but they
basically I'm like man this usada guy
suck uh they just broke up with the UFC
over Conor McGregor's return to the UFC
smoked blunts have you seen McGregor oh
he's on Roy have you seen him big as his
table I don't know details of ite Dam
yeah like huge CU they were going to
make him wait 6 months or like make him
back dat his P or some [__] and they
it's insane that like I don't know how
that's going to work now if the fighters
aren't going to get tested or no he's
the high school football star like
they're going to adjust the stuff for
him he gets an A so he's in though so
he's in I don't know it seems you see
him bro he looks he looks like a bulldog
yeah he does he doesn't even look the
same dude anymore mhm I don't know I'm
starting to follow a little more fights
are cool it's fights are cool there's
for
UFC I want Juiced up McGregor versus
Juiced up Nate Diaz to go back at
ited out Fighters and just let it happen
you watch the knuckle see the knuckle
League when you got some time go on
YouTube put in Beckle bare knuckle
League it's disgusting like these fools
are are breaking their faces off the
team fights that we watched oh there's
five on five UFC have you seen that Russ
I got to check that out bro five on five
and say I knock you out now it's four on
five you know we all jump that guy bro
it would be [__] amazing if there
could be a free-for-all every man for
themselves like 10 guys in there last
man standing wins the prize money I
would knock everybody out from the back
I would enter that [__] bro I just lay
in the corner like I doing Call of Duty
wa if you guys can kill each other I'm
going come out and win this I don't play
games I suck but WWF [__] like Royal
Rumble when I used to play that I would
just stay in the corner on the top
turnbuckle and just watch uh and then I
jump it at the end I went did you have
laser Tron growing up what laser Tron
like you know laser tag you going oh
laser tag yeah yeah our [__] was called
laser Tron it had other it yeah it had
go-karts it had arcade it had all kinds
of from New York oh hell yeah maybe fun
stuff happens cuz I feel like you hung
out at that uh at that Hideout from the
first Ninja Turtles
movie Soldier we talk about this whole
the time and that song's playing do it
you want menth or regulars yeah my
name Mee Jones by default yeah makes me
Casey you don't play hockey I now was my
first sport oh that's right huh sorry
he's from the cold oh yeah badass that's
right I forgot I forgot oh so we wanted
to bring up uh real quick you have some
ridiculous ass tweets and I just want to
know what you were thinking when you
said them all right can I read this one
please because that sounds like some
[__] I say okay we just want to get you
to elaborate on this all right no what's
that what's what's that you don't have
to read it white people from Texas and
Mexicans from Texas have an Unbreak Bond
a bond built by trucks cocaine and
construction yeah true yeah every true
Mexican and every true uh White Texan
loves trucks construction and cocaine
man it just it's how it goes I don't
know and beef I feel like the Tweet is
self-explanatory yeah beef steak it
sounds like he wrote it is really what
it
is 100% bro it sounds just like anytime
I see like the the guys who are like
voting for Trump and who like we got to
stop illegals I'm like you just look
like a light-skinned illegal though like
you guys are the same people oh yeah
yeah the the Mexicans for Trump in Texas
is that we talking no I'm talking about
like like white guys like white country
dudes who are like who are like against
like illegals I'm like bro you're the
same people you guys have the same
dreams you want to start a family and
drive a truck and go work hard do some
lines yeah do lines you know I mean and
you live right by the border if anything
you're the most Mexican American I've
ever seen you're basically there there
is those crazy those dudes who like
Mexicans who are like Republican Mexican
what that's [__] nuts it's CRA what
we say like
uh uh you know probably can you know
probably cancel I have one a lot of them
a lot of them were was and I guess cuz
maybe that's where they got there first
so they've been there for more
Generations but a lot of those Mexicans
are like closer to the Border like in
the valley of Texas like Brownsville
Mallen and [__] well San Antonio Texas
is the first time like that city was the
first place where I heard like older
Mexican dudes speak good English it
freaked me out in
Dallas I feel like it's kind of like
rule of thumb like if you see a Mexican
dude like over the age of 30 you kind of
just assume to speak Spanish to them you
assume they don't even know English and
I remember San Antonio I was like a
teenager I went to like their Market or
whatever supposed to be all like Mexican
and when I was walking out the restroom
there was this old guy I was walking in
and the old guy was walking out and I
said excuse me in Spanish I was like
permo and he said all yours bud and I
looked like what the [__] like you're
not supposed to do that you guys don't
make you like that yeah and I think it's
just because there's been more
generations of Mexicans there longer so
I got to be honest I would look twice
too wow yeah make you holy [__] I saw
that I was like I'm going back to Dallas
where where the Mex speak
Spanish damn dude like well Texas
Mexicans and California Mexicans are um
Polar Opposites I feel I have from El
Paso and I just noticed little things
I'm like wow you like you guys love
cocaine yeah like you just do it because
you're awake yeah it's not like yo these
do Dr like no I'm taking my kids to
school like holy [__] I don't know it's
like the access but like I think it's we
have such good weed here that
everybody's like no I'm I'm kind of good
being up all day I'm just going to smoke
some weed that has to be it yeah um but
all right here we
go I like that
one I had a dream I kept dropping my
blun and woke up frustrated oh yeah I
remember that dream that's a [__] up
Dream It's a t-shirt it is it is a
t-shirt cuz I have those dreams but I'm
late for school but three months late
for school and I have all FS I have that
dream a lot I wake up just like what am
I forgetting I have this dream where I
keep ending up at like school and and I
keep like they keep telling me like yay
that's your first day and I'm just like
[__] like where's my schedule and you
can't find the office I can't find
theice office I can't find my schedule I
can't find the office or my schedule
yeah it's weird I have too order the
class you can't find your locker I don't
know where I'm going I don't recognize
the school or it's yeah I don't
recognize it's and then I have other
ones where it's been like halfway
through the semester one of my teachers
is like you haven't been in this math
class A whole semester like there's no
way you're going to pass and then I keep
forgetting how to get to my next class
what my schedule was again like it's
[__] weird bro we just talked about
Weir but the blown one I just remember I
kept dropping it in the dream and I
couldn't like smoke it like I was like
God damn it have you ever successfully
knocked a [__] out in your dream
no same okay never mind I punch through
water in
dreams you mean like it's slow okay yeah
of course or I hit somebody and nothing
happens I'm hit him as hard as I can
even if I'm hitting them hard sometimes
I can't even make the fist or if I do
make the fist then it's like I'm not
doing any damage and I'm just pissed
yeah it's like a shitty video game I
don't know if we've talked about this
but have you ever thrown a punch in real
life through the during while you're
sleeping yes it's connected with the
dream and you actually throw I don't I
mean I wouldn't know I'm asleep I like
wake up yeah mid punch I'm like oh [__]
ioke I had a broken collar bone did that
broke my
collar you rebr broke it yeah Mar throws
hard ass hooks dude he puts his hips
into it I don't know I didn't need to
sleep apparently I do that his ex-wife
got knocked out she died oh [__] yeah
yeah that's how you met April broke my
collar
bone let I was moving in with some
girl that's Marty Marty's a classic let
me slide in and L with
you that's what I did that's my dad one
time his hand was all swollen cuz he
just like in his sleep just swung and
hit the the [__] out the nightstand so
like yeah and his hand was just swollen
like like with all his force is your dad
like a hardworking dude yeah okay so is
my dad so like no that he probably
didn't even care yeah he he was just
like a [__] [__] yeah I've seen my dad
bust his face open and go
oh we've talked about it like my dad I
don't know what it is he was just made
with no pain sensor bro didn't he like
break his finger or something wasn't
there a story or am I making that up in
my head smashed his foot flat with a
safe cuz we were we do moving and his
foot got smashed flat and all his toell
were coming off and I get I get grossed
out easy so he just he just made me
throw up that's all I don't know if you
want to hear nasty [__] someone else
came I like how you're just like my dad
made me throw up like bro his toes were
coming out how do you think he fell no
he was fine he don't give a [__] you
didn't care 2 months later his toenails
are almost all the way off and he's like
Thomas come here and and his toes are
out in the cast right I'm like what CU
he knows I get grossed out quick my
dad sorry and I walk up I walk up and
then he's like come here and I walk up
I'm like what's up and I get to the top
of the stairs because we're in Oregon
from the basement and
I he was had his foot in his mouth his
toenail and he ripped the toenail off
with his teeth and then blood
went and I [__] threw him right on
the ground I'm like you [__] cleaning
it I'm not [__] cleaning it hor mov
and I went back downstairs I've talked
to you about this before that's
psychotic my dad's a
monster he doesn't care dude he got what
he wanted man he wanted to gross meow he
[__] succeeded I threw up on the
ground yeah my dad's a one of those like
yo I love crank but now I'm D have you
ever heard of trophobia he's like good
now where uh little holes and Horrors
make you cringe and freak out oh bro
don't even show me that bro you have
that I didn't even know that was a real
thing I do it to April to the point that
I'll be like oh my God look at this and
she looks at it and [__] DRS in the
air and freaks out I'm going to start
fing I'm just afraid of this the water
and
Heights I have that apparently oh my God
I didn't know that was a thing dude I'm
afraid of Chucky I was about to say that
scares me as much as like Chucky used to
scare me as a kid yo bro what's your
family's personal name we're related
they have to be no there's no there's no
there's no other way around this my
number one fear as a kid was Chucky my
dad used to buy me Chucky to I was so
afraid of Chucky that at my cousin's
house they had a Chucky doll but not the
scary Chucky they had Chucky from rugat
oh Chuy and I was like I was like I'm
not even going to risk it why they even
risk why you going to make that Chucky
redhead they knew what they were doing
yeah they're trying to make it okay I
was like he's redhead and his name's
Chucky I'm not going [__] near Chuck
he a he was soft I will watch on the
cartoon no problem yeah but in person
the my sister had porcelain dolls
everybody thought she liked him as a kid
so my sister always get a porcelain doll
for Christmas my grandma and I would
[__] put stuff on them every night
cuz we sh a room I ain't trying to have
a doll choke me in my sleep I watch
Chucky man I'm good anyway yeah we might
be related my aunt my aunt had like a
collection of dolls her mom and uh like
all like got up on a wall like a lot of
them and when you're in there as a
little kid it feels like the walls are
like 100t tall just full of dolls and I
would be like that one looked at me I
just like run out [__] that just creep
oh yeah I would put him on the bottom of
the shelves put stuff on top cuz if it
moves I know we could throw it away and
then my little brother ended up loving
the doll so much so he kept the Chucky
doll for eight years I had to look at it
dude just out of Sprite for you he loved
it he was a little baby I like yeah of
course you love it and I can't take it
from him sorry we got way off topic my
bad my bad we're way off topic talking
about Chucky and [__] you take that
picture of just to be safe when I leave
here I'm going to like not look at the
don't worry don't worry God see it's a
real did you know it has a name no I
didn't know it had a name it's called
Trypophobia that's a badass name yeah it
is it sounds like an album title that's
a sick ass name trophobia I might name
this [__] episode that [__] I'm bad
phobic bro I didn't even know that was a
thing I didn't know either I just know
that when I see that [__] I'm
like [__] off I feel you cuz at the
beginning of Dexter I can't watch cuz
it's all close as [__] eating eggs out
he with that [__] sorry C banga all
right
October 31st man I I'm going to eat a
shitload of candy cuz that's the day I'm
like you know it's okay American I eat
some candy and we're going to watch the
episode I'm excited yeah hell yeah dud
uh do you have any plans to watch it n
I'm not going to watch that man what I
was there I know you were there but you
got to watch you're not going to be with
your mom like all right it's coming out
all right I'll watch like Clips you know
I've already watched I've watched it
enough and during the editing process I
no I feel you but it's like hey it's
like when signf like yo my my Show's
coming up also man I don't know if this
is like I think this is just thing with
Comics a lot like you see it and you see
everything with any clip not only just
with the special but it's going to it's
going to hurt 10 times worse with the
special but anytime you watch your
footage you're watching things you could
have done better yeah and so I was like
[__] I don't want to see this he edit my
videos and we I used to edit my videos
like oh [__] that I got stop doing that
with my face yeah it's all right like yo
if I was watching the first time this
say weirdo some of the jokes on there
are are like little short ones and I
kept doing them a little bit after and I
started adding things to him and I love
them way more now than when I put them
out there I'm like damn like it's like
if you built a car with like a nice
[__] 442 or whatever you were able to
get like 460 horsepower out of it but
then 2 weeks after you released it you
figured out how to get like 480
horsepower you're just like [__] almost
but whatever it's out there you got the
good metaphors and [__] yeah no no
working pry well dog [__] cars I [__]
with this this is our kind of
episode where can everybody uh oh sorry
go ahead I was just going to say I know
the fans are going to want to hear uh
what was it like working with Mexican OT
oh man yeah Mexican OT is [__] dope
man uh it cool we he like uh I don't I
think he like rented out this little
studio in uh in Dallas area his manager
was the one that hit me up I had to talk
to Mexican OT through just like
Instagram here and there cuz I was like
a fan you know and uh his manager was
like man Mexican OT is you know he
putting this album together it's almost
finished and he was saying if you could
do like some skits on there like comedy
skits whatever I had never done that I
was like [__] bro I don't know if I can
be funny in that way I was like
listening to skits and stuff but I
always like that stuff so I like I'm
down let's do something you know that's
hip-hop Chris Rock remember B to do that
that was my that was my main like like I
was like yo Chris Rock did uh so this is
not even like that old of an album but
Buster Rhymes had that [__] album bro
I can't even remember the name of it let
me look at her real quick you got it's
that it's that one where he's wearing
the it's like he's wearing that mask
it's like a end of the world type name
or some [__]
armag something like that but uh Chris
Rock does a lot of like the skits on
there there's one where he's like take
notes he's like bust a bust the name you
trust it's like a god
MC and uh extinction level event too
yeah yeah damn some end of the world
[__] that is the end of the world [__]
um and I I don't know just stuff like
that man and and other you know audio
skits that like Comics have done and
[__] so I was like hell yeah like I want
to I want to I want to work with him I
was also just a fan of him I thought
that' be cool and he rented out this
little studio and they had a marel
versus Capcom 2 in there sick yeah so
that's the first we did was play that
nah um it might have been the first Mar
versus Capcom I can't remember exactly I
just remember I got whooped were you
Blanca though huh no I was uh storm oh
that's pretty [__] up man she can only
bring the weather yeah
um but anyway um I had I had written
maybe like 10 different skits I told him
about them we did a we did a chunk of
them he only used like a few of them um
but man it was cool it was just weird
like getting like I didn't I didn't
think about like there was there was a
lot of people there oh [__] yeah and I
was like damn I got to do these like
skits in the studio I never been in a
[__] sound booth I was like now I'm
going to do these skits with this dude
and like I was like [__] it like like
here we go and uh it was fun bro he was
mad cool he was just like yeah yeah
let's let's do him and he heard him he
liked him and he was he was ready to go
it took us like a few tries to get each
little skit down but he was mad cool and
we're just trading like mushroom stories
and just kind of trading stories in
general that dude's mad he's he's good
people oh yeah mad cool yeah we we we
were talking about him for like what a
year and then started popping like yep
there it is we we knew it bro and he's
the only dude that's my height that
could do a back flip yeah he's doing
back flip how many times they say I I'm
going do a backflip one day how many
times have I said this [__] I watched
him do a backflip um he's definitely one
of those people that when he sees
somebody do it like he can grasp how to
do it I think I don't know I could be
wrong I'm not that I'm not that person
yeah or the [__] learner from the I
suck at school basically that's what I'm
trying to say um random as hell so yeah
we just wanted to know cuz that was a a
get asked every day to get mexic he was
supposed to be here last month and he
got on his tour like when you have time
you come so we have a lot of people
asking for you Mexican OT and what's
that [__] dude oh sorry not the
[__] dude but my Shane Gillis the one
I want his ass on was hilarious bro that
dude's the goat he's hilarious man and I
think he's kind of bringing back like oh
we could say stupid [__] thank you that
D is [__] hilarious I don't I don't
watch a whole lot of like comedy
specials just cuz I'm afraid that I'll
start like trying to write jokes in
their voice right but um so I'll watch
like chunks at a time but I was I was
watching every time I watch his first
special and then I started watching the
second one and like bro I can't stop
watching like that sh just funny i' seen
like three or four times already just on
road trips in the Sprinter like you just
want to laugh oh that's a good idea
that's the perfect time to watch a spot
it's the perfect time um I thought these
two joints were like bills on Capitol
Hill you School Rock School House Rock
yeah I'm Just a Bill Bill yeah yeah
exactly like it's just get political
good eye bro no it's just a blunt and
lighter it's our and [__] I thought it
was weed and like the bill to pass weed
no I don't know about politics he I just
got to explain what Democrat and
Republican was three weeks ago bro so I
don't know about politics either I don't
know about it I watched The Schoolhouse
Rock thing and I still don't understand
how oh no you just like the you like the
foess she lives outside [__] homeless
like don't worry bro we'll bring you in
That's How It Ends that's a that's a
good ass movie or whatever it is um yes
and on Schoolhouse Rock where can
everybody find your uh Instagrams
twitters it's just Ralph Barbosa Ralph
Barbosa
03 03 on everything on everything is it
rough Barbosa 03 why the 03 um I don't
know my son was born on the
3 of his month I don't want to say his
whole birthday I got you I was also B
born on the third of my month Alan
Iverson was number three thank you I was
not wanting to say that thank
you three is just cool number that's why
I had three yeah all right I I didn't
know I just had to ask you know what I
mean all right so across all platforms
they can find you there on YouTube it's
just Ralph Barosa 03 also it might be
just because I want I might have wanted
to keep it the same but if you either
way it do pop up we'll pop it up on the
screen also but October 31st Netflix
Netflix cabanga cabanga if you could
dress up as one thing for Halloween what
would it be uh and costumes didn't
matter cuz you can just have it
magically what would it be uh the
Michael Keaton Batman s we're [__]
related it's my favorite Batman I just
they have that at the car museum down
here I just saw the Batmobile the
891 I have a video of it from two days
ago 3 days ago as soon as I get enough
money I'm going to buy it you know like
Travis Scott he did yeah I don't know
why he did the brown I don't know why he
did it looks so stupid Brown just do the
just do like it didn't it didn't work it
didn't work but um took a shot I would
think uh I'm still going to try but uh
Danny DeVito and Matilda Mr when his hat
gets
stuck fibers areused that's that's what
I want to be for Halloween oh yeah all
right so all right Halloween guys go
ahead and check it out cowabanga on
Netflix October 31st in case you don't
know when Halloween is f all right Ralph
thank you very much for being here
appreciate you hey thanks for having me
man great episode man thank you for
being here appreciate it man thank you
so much guys this has been the dope as
usual podcast have a dope s day yeah
nice all right oh perfect smokeless we
weren't sure if you still smok so you
hold a hell of joints so we're like all
right y could have smoked no dude it
gets boxed instantly I appreciate that
it's soundproof so there's no
[Music]
leaks
perfect
[Music]